chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
la question orale numéro 400 de monsieur
francis grignon à madame la ministre de
la culture et de la communication merci
monsieur le président madame les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question porte sur le développement de
fr3 en région le territoire compte 24
stations régionales de france 3 une
centaine de chaînes de télévision
locales et un ensemble de fonds de
soutien à la production la création en
région s'appuie sur des dizaines de
sociétés de production reconnu qui
emploient des auteurs des réalisateurs
des comédiens et des équipes techniques
le potentiel de france 3 en région est
donc considérable pourtant france 3
consacre très peu d'heures aux
programmes régionaux qui représente
moins de 10% de son temps d'antenne main
dicton le projet de réforme de la chaîne
publique france 3 présente donc un enjeu
majeur d'aménagement du territoire en
termes économique culturel et plus
globalement sociétal c'est pourquoi
madame la ministre
j'aimerais savoir comment le
gouvernement entend mettre en oeuvre la
vocation pleinement régionales de france
3 à l'horizon 2015
j'ai bien conscience que vous ne pourrez
pas m'indiquer aujourd'hui la
composition de la grille de programmes
à cet horizon néanmoins j'aimerais poser
cette question très en amont des études
qui vont être faite car j'aimerais
savoir dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes
et ce que vous êtes dans une logique de
stabilité des programmes régionaux sein
de france 3 dans une logique de
réduction ou dans une logique
d'augmentation de ces programmes je pose
ces questions aujourd'hui car l'ensemble
des acteurs régionaux qui travaillent
autour de l'audiovisuel en région sont
très attentifs à tout ce qui sera décidé
dans ce domaine merci monsieur grignon
madame la ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur francis grignon
je veux tout d'abord
vous assurez de l'attachement du
gouvernement à la mission de proximité
qui incombe à france télévisions au
travers évidemment de france 3 en tout
premier lieu vous le savez la situation
financière de l'entreprise france
télévisions est aujourd'hui contrainte
la dégradation des recettes
publicitaires en est largement
responsable mais nous avons aussi
demandé à france télévisions une
contribution à l'effort national de
redressement des finances publiques de
l'ordre de 2 % sur trois ans donc d'ici
là cela a conduit l'état à engager avec
france télévisions une discussion en vue
de réviser le contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens 2011 2015 au terme de ces travaux
qui ont été présentés validé par le
conseil d'administration le 11 juillet
dernier un nouvel équilibre a été
définie qui demande certes un effort
d'économie à l'entreprise mais qui
conforte ses grandes missions de service
public et notamment ses grandes missions
en matière de proximité et de la
proximité comme je vous le dis c'est
bien entendu france 3
le projet d'avenant donc au comme pour
2013 2015 prévoit que la stratégie
d'affirmation d'identité régionale de
france 3 se poursuit
nous devons d'abord évidemment conforter
le rôle essentiel de l'information
régionale puisqu'on le sait
d'information régionale sur les locales
de france 3 et sur les antennes de
france 3 est appréciée de nos
concitoyens et répond à un service
public de grande qualité
nous devons aussi réfléchir et je vous
remercie d'avoir souligné à la manière
d'élargir les plages des émissions un
régional il y a bien sûr l'exemple de
vie à stella en corse où on voit qu'il
ya une société de production des
producteurs locaux etc qui contribue
fortement à l'identité
de la chaîne pour ce qui est de la corse
nous n'aurons avec les contraintes
budgétaires qui sont les nôtres
évidemment il n'est pas envisageable de
pouvoir avoir le même système qui
s'applique dans toutes les régions
néanmoins je suis extrêmement ouverte à
une discussion large qui devra commencer
prochainement savoir comment valoriser
au mieux le savoir faire non seulement
des équipes de france 3 mais aussi
valoriser les initiatives locales les
initiatives régionales
bref renforcer la mission de proximité
de france 3 d'abord du point de vue de
l'information qui est une réussite sur
sur la chaîne comme sur l'ensemble de
france télévisions mais aussi du point
de vue des des émissions des programmes
qui effectivement peuvent aussi naître
dans nos régions et il trouvé leur
public
néanmoins cela nécessitera des
discussions approfondies et pour
l'instant aucun aucune décision n'a été
prise en la matière parce que ça doit se
faire dans une concertation large en
tout cas soyez assurés de ma
détermination à préserver l'identité de
proximité qui est que représente france
3 est aussi à travailler avec vous avec
l'ensemble du parlement sur les missions
à envisager pour voir évoluer france 3
je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre monsieur
grignon merci madame et les ministres
pour ses premiers éléments de réponse
vous comprendrez que je viens je ne
viens pas de corse et l'alsace une
région aussi à forte identité dans
laquelle nous sommes très sensibles à
l'action de france 3 j'ai lu récemment
avec beaucoup d'intérêt que le
secrétaire général de france télévisions
avait su trouver un juste équilibre
entre les exigences des uns et des
autres vous venez de le confirmer dans
le contrat d'objectifs et de moyens je
puis simplement vous dire que dans notre
région la région proprement dite est
prête aussi à discuter avec vous pour
voir quels sont les aménagements maximum
en tout état de cause je vois que vous
êtes dans un esprit très positif de
proximité jeu
merci